[Music]
in chain-reaction news submitted by
taiga and Leia our life all right
two people have accused Katy Perry of
sexual misconduct I thought it was up to
three now up to three ply heard what's
happened alone think about it I know the
fiance no no they're about to get
married get married she got the ugliest
ring really it's so ugly dude I got a
friend who had an ugly ring to it I
don't know how to say it it's like
though I don't think it's our position
to say anything sure you want to be very
honest with people but yeah that's true
no I'm not honest with anyone you know I
wasn't saying I was gonna say it but I'm
just saying I don't even know how to say
it like if I hated yet yeah it's like
this is ugly
would you say that most like people
would be like oh then I would love to
get sexually harassed by a caper
yeah that's a guy yeah sure it was a
woman what if she was dancing while she
was doing it they're like oh no no oh
that's so it's kind of awkward but I
know I know most guys would probably
still want to get I don't know your ass
better get in the way of a guy's dick
not for me it's about how she dances
yeah thank you but she has Russia has
like nice boobs though it doesn't matter
if she's not a good dancer out instead
of jiggling like seductively they're
going like because she can't dance see I
don't like it when they wobble like that
it's a surgery you like it still you're
just still kind of guy all right okay so
like with the two accusers oh [ __ ]
what a picture yeah was it a thumbnail
[Laughter]
well constructed drop shadow so they get
the [ __ ] layer yeah Wow
you know things you don't say okay so
Katy Perry here this guy is evils Josh
and this chick her name is Tina and so
Josh was the love interest in Katy
Perry's music video for teenage dreams
oh that does something yeah so
the video the video school - this was
back in 2010 when they did the music
video so on the 9th anniversary of the
music video that's when Josh decided to
come out with what had happened to him
what happened then
so he was saying that after they met
they sing a worship song and she was
cool and kind and what other people
around she was cold and even called the
act of kissing him gross - the entire
set
so he's like he said that that was
pretty embarrassing like when they're
sitting here kissing scenes
yeah they kissed a lot in that music
video oh they made out a lot so he was
saying like yeah it's kind of
embarrassing but I gave him my all and
and he even adds that his ex was
cheating on him and the his daughter was
just a toddler so then he endured that
for his daughter's sake so it was
disgusting kissing his [ __ ] but I did
it for the [ __ ] money
no like being embarrassed by her saying
it was gross
each other people around you pretty much
roasted him on set yeah pretty much
so then he said that after the first day
of shooting that she invited him to a
strip club in Santa Barbara and she
didn't decline he declined Wow what are
they like Santa Barbara strip clubs
picture a bunch of beach girls or
something a lot of college girls how
people in Santa Barbara yeah yeah it's
you know like a strip kind of place you
know like is it is it shaped like a boat
or like you know I mean it's a classy
stripper place where all the chicks come
out and Tommy Bahama shirts oh cremate
demon you know the fun part is the
mystery and taking it off not really
like just all super big yeah all right
so then he said that he saw Katie a
couple times after she broke up with
Russell and then that there was this one
time that he took a friend to this dude
Johnny or jet Jeff would check with
jiske not with jiske Johnny Wujek Wujek
oh dang dude that black thing does a lot
to the screen oh yeah you can that's all
we're Justin
okay so Johnny Wujek birthday party
when he saw her he hugged her or like
they hugged each other and he said that
she was still his crush but as he turned
to introduce his friend to her
she pulled down his adidas sweats and
underwear as far as she could to show a
couple of her guys of her guy friends
and the crowd around them she
humiliatingly sucked his dead penis show
the dicks showed his penis that is weird
claiming that's [ __ ] if it's true
yeah I have it's true so he was just
saying like can you imagine how pathetic
and embarrassed I felt yeah I would have
been like let me get hard first damn
they're gonna get the wrong impression
you know ya better think Marisa if I
knew you were gonna do this can you
please tell me ahead cuz I didn't [ __ ]
shave you know like what's a flan cuz
I'm a girl we're not shower
yeah I know I don't you don't get a real
representation if it's like caught off
guard you know I just wanna be falsely
portrayed yeah that's like hey Jo do
something funny like what the [ __ ] dude
I wasn't prepared for this [ __ ] anyway
we pulled on your path do something
funny I just say this now because our
culture is set on proving men of power
are perverse but females with power are
just as disgusting so for all heard yeah
equality is an amazing leader hurt her
songs are mainly great empowering
anthems and that's it I continued to
watch I continue to watch her use clips
of her music videos for her world tour
and then her DVD only highlighting one
of her male co-stars and it was me I
made around six hundred and fifty
dollars in total of Teenage Dream
because he did it for exposure may be
glad to be booked you know me Jesus guys
on set yeah he probably thought it was a
good deal he was like yo how was her
love interest in his music video which
might get him a lot more other gigs so
people just do that a lot so he had been
supporting her throughout all these
years and like saying like you know she
was great and all this stuff but then
now the counterculture mm-hmm this came
out and so a lot of people so then that
Johnny Wujek guy
claimed that that never happened at his
birthday party
he said oh hell no let's see he said oh
hell no I'm not about to let you make
accusations against my friend like this
this is such [ __ ] Katie would never
do something like that we all know about
your ongoing obsession with her since
the day of filming that video you were
writing her music and planning an
imaginary future with her it's not okay
to do this to people who have done
nothing but uplift and inspire others
focus on your life and your daughter and
move on Josh I'll be praying for you we
all will
and so people are saying like just
because you had a great experience with
her doesn't mean that this could have
happened to him and so he responded to
that comment saying like you weren't
there at the moment like you went
somewhere else oh okay so it was his
party but I thought she was patting him
in front of his fans Oh Johnny
is the birthday boy so she's the one
that I just read the comments there was
that right yeah but then Josh was the
one that got that and he got passed in
front of whom like people yeah well he
loved people come out exactly yeah cuz I
thought I thought if Keillor friend
friends with Katie where was this
because I thought that Johnny guy
saw it before the statement but then
yeah damn okay that's cool that does ice
amount of Katie yeah exactly
so then now the second allegation cuz I
don't know about the third but this
Russian TV personality named Tina she
detailed an experience that she had with
Katy Perry at a party saying that is
this party Katy Perry attempted to kiss
her so she said once I write what wait
once I was invited to a private party
with Katy Perry where she being pretty
tipsy chose me as an object for the
manifestation of her passion I managed
to fight back strength training was not
in vain and Katy instantly found a new
victim for kisses hugs and dirty dances
oh I love how these people have to go
I'm so glad I had those table with a
weird Daleks like I'm so glad that I
[ __ ] head did those bicep curls
because I used it in this [ __ ] moment
so the third one was the American Idol
thing remember that okay we should have
kissed that kidney to other things
like I didn't think it was either I'm
just saying no what I'm saying is that's
not them coming out and saying like she
sexually assaulted me because these
people are these people but the other
two things that Katy Perry's involved in
here is back in 2017 she was caught on
video touching Shawn Mendes but while he
was on the red carpet and back then she
was only 18 and then just making fun but
then this other thing that he was
talking about is this American Idol
contestant named Benjamin he was 19 he
was pretty much tricked into kissing her
and I show you that video I'll show you
guys the video both videos sound like a
Madonna moment the garment yeah well
yeah oh and I didn't like it cuz yeah
short hair what okay what on the cheek
she knocked him over with it these kids
such a [ __ ] virgin
[Laughter]
true cuz guys will do things to be funny
and it still isn't okay yeah like 40
times on janky party yeah come on man
looking high school yeah what 500 bucks
be okay I mean what about too good and
Ryan's got a great times because he
wants to grant yeah yeah it's like
what's it like sperm oh yeah he said
that she would have done if she would
have just asked him like straight up
that he would have declined cuz he's all
white no like hey like he was he really
wanted to save his first kiss for a
relationship and like fine dude I know
but this kidneys get his ass beat a
little bit now but I saw Katy Perry and
I was like I don't like you right now
but he did her hair was like rose he did
that he didn't feel like he was sexually
assaulted or anything by her but this is
just like another forcing her power upon
others yeah so like if it was a guy then
oh yeah never know
for sure there's a couple stud guys
cancel from the herbs
yeah cuz you'll be like Oh 18 year old
version you never kissed bring your ass
over here
I'm gonna give you a first [ __ ] kiss
yeah it's old imagine Simon donation
Simon Cowell
[ __ ] vomited his mouth it falls the
18 year old dude of Seacrest did that
[ __ ] we'd all be like shitty straight
okay crazy that's crazy
[Music]